i'm greg jarrett i'm shannon bream i'm
steve ducey and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday march 2nd 2022 i'm jessica
rosenthal the president delivered his
first official state of the union
address and as much as inflation and
changing covet guidelines matter the
focus was on ukraine and russia what's
happening in ukraine is
extraordinary
i'm dave anthony she blamed then
president trump for the capital riot
it's already cost liz cheney a
republican leadership role in the house
and it could cost the congresswoman her
seat as he backs a republican challenger
in wyoming but when she
participated in what was a sham
impeachment without due process
i was really pretty disgusted
and i'm david marcus
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
president biden's first state of the
union speech opened with a focus on the
state of ukraine currently being
attacked by russia russia's vladimir
putin sought to shake the very
foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend
to his menacing ways
but he badly miscalculated
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
instead
he met with a small
wall of strength he never anticipated or
imagined he met ukrainian people while
he praised the ukrainian people and
their president acknowledging the
presence of one of the first lady's
guests ukraine's ambassador to the u.s
he said the u.s will not engage russia
in ukraine our troops are being sent to
nato allies to defend what he said is
every inch of nato territory receiving a
standing ovation from members of both
parties when he pledged to go after the
corrupt leaders and russian oligarchs
ill-gotten gains
masks were noticeably absent in the
house chamber as cdc guidelines have
shifted on that front the president said
his coveted policies worked especially
on the economic front but said we've
reached a new moment that kovid need no
longer control our lives he also
mentioned inflation saying new efforts
to keep supply chains open and
competitive especially in shipping along
with efforts to increase manufacturing
at home especially semiconductor chip
manufacturing are critical but pressed
congress to pass elements of his now
stalled out build back better
legislation including funding for child
care elder care and prescription drugs
the president also addressed crime
briefly we should all agree the answer
is not to defund the police is to fund
the police
we talk with fox news radio political
analyst josh crosshauer and fox news
radio washington d.c correspondent jared
halpern about whether the president
accomplished what he set out to do with
his first state of the union address
this was a stay the course speech
for those expecting the president to
abandon build back better even though he
didn't say those words that was
essentially the gist of his domestic
agenda for anyone to really expect a
course correction they're not gonna hear
it from what the president said
so you know i think he said what he
needed to say but in terms of the
president's strategy his agenda his
tactics going forward it's not going to
change except on the national security
and the foreign policy front and
confronting vladimir putin and russia
he did spend much of the beginning of
his speech talking about ukraine and and
russia and specifically vladimir putin
i'm wondering despite the pledge
that there will be no american boots on
the ground
we're not engaging in a no-fly zone
which would engage nato or u.s troops
who's ever in charge of enforcing that
no-fly zone
if things worsen and if this lasts for
months as our own fox news correspondent
trey yingston kiev has said it might
do things change do we see a different
level of american engagement and
involvement possibly this year
i don't think you're going to see troops
on the ground in ukraine that was a
pretty firm red line that the president
spoke even as he offered stern rhetoric
to support the ukrainians to give
military aid to the ukrainians made a
nod to the ukrainian ambassador to the
united states
but he also said in that same paragraph
we're not putting any military forces on
the ground in ukraine so i think that's
going to be the status quo for a long
time the
look the politics in europe are
different than the politics in the
united states european politics changed
overnight with the war raging on their
territory in the united states ukraine
is an issue and this was an important
speech and the word spiden said about
support for ukraine were significant but
i don't think the politics are the more
people are gonna weigh the economy over
uh what's going on in europe in the
short term
jared what you've watched many state of
the union speeches too many probably
never
was the most like sort of galvanizing
moment for i guess both parties was the
most bipartisan moment maybe the most
emotional moment as well
seeing ukraine's ambassador having the
first lady hug her as the president said
we will
stop putin no more to putin
i mean the whole speech especially that
first part was striking because this is
the first state of the union that a
president has been able to deliver in
two decades without u.s forces engaged
in combat operations in afghanistan and
instead the attention now is in europe
this russian invasion
and the united states and european
allies rallying around that and i was
struck by the number of lawmakers
republicans and democrats wearing blue
and yellow the colors of the ukrainian
flag members of congress walking into
the house chamber waving the ukrainian
flag and that solidarity was striking
it's hard to maybe pinpoint sort of
historically obviously presidents like i
said have given states of the union
in times of international crises when
u.s forces are committed to wars in the
middle east but it is generational to
see
conflict like this in continental europe
and it certainly overshadowed i think a
lot of what the president probably had
intended to say
this was a speech that was delivered for
the first time in two years without
members of congress wearing masks
without members of congress largely
isolated because of the pandemic
here in the district of columbia the
mass mandate has been dropped the
vaccine requirements have been dropped
schools across the country are starting
to drop mass mandates if they haven't
already and that wasn't the moment
that's going to stand out in this speech
the moment that's going to stand out in
this speech to your point is the
president singling out the ukrainian
ambassador and vowing that the united
states will do what it can
to help that country not just
immediately but in the aftermath with
what we expect to be a pretty pricey
rebuilding operation given what we've
just went through for the past two years
jared of this pandemic are you surprised
it wasn't a bigger focus of the
president's speech no because what's
happening in ukraine is extraordinary
you know even members of congress have
sort of said listen we have different
approaches on sort of how these
sanctions should have been delivered
pre-invasion post-invasion but now that
this has happened there is
almost unanimous sentiment in congress
that funding is going to be provided in
the form of arms in the form of
humanitarian assistance we're not sure
how that price tag is going to look
maybe how it's going to be allocated but
the idea of congress signing up probably
in the next couple of weeks to fund
ukraine to the tune of billions of
dollars seems pretty
locked solid at this point
josh we know based on polling at least
at this point inflation is really top of
mind for americans and for voters did
the president come with a pitch on
inflation that americans can find some
relief in i mean it sounded like he was
pushing you know for things to be made
in america chip manufacturing pledging
to create this maritime commission
that's going to focus on competition of
shipping that might help address supply
chain issues are those the kinds of
things americans want to hear right now
i mean his pitch was basically built
back better and then cutting down waste
fraud and abuse i mean that didn't work
the first time around and simply putting
lipstick on a pig doesn't change the
fundamental reality that joe manchin is
needed to pass any legislation through
congress and you know look this is a
political address i think he's trying to
sell build back better in a different
way and maybe it'll help him
in terms of how the public views him
it's just policy-wise not gonna help him
pass it through congress josh is right
the the message may be changing the math
is not changing congress is the same you
still need
at least 50 votes in the united states
senate joe manchin
has talked about his concerns with
inflation has talked about his concerns
as it relates to to spending this kind
of money in the current economic
situation now that being said are there
elements of buildback better that joe
manchin has has been supportive of
absolutely but
it's still gonna matter how that is
is sort of legislatively handled right
now the president's gonna do what
presidents historically do after states
of the union beginning wednesday morning
he will go on the road and he will sell
this agenda
but to josh's point it may be more of a
midterm message because the numbers in
the united states senate will not change
because the president delivered a speech
um let's talk about some of the things
that were missing or absent from the
speech there was no reference to
afghanistan
there were fleeting mentions right of
items that
you know
democratic voters really care about like
voting rights and abortion related
issues
there was no mention of president trump
are these some of the things what did
you make josh of the of those either
fleeting mentions or absent of mentions
that that is a great observation jessica
because
what was the first message in 2022 from
this white house voting rights in speech
in georgia
you know we had the virginia governor's
race just a few months earlier all about
trump which terry mcauliffe lost because
of that incessant focus on the former
president that base first messaging has
turned off a whole lot of voters so even
though the president is giving the same
pitch writ large he's not talking about
the base first issues that really
dominated the first year of his
presidency and i think that's very
politically important but again it's
because of what the dynamic is in the
united states congress right it's not as
if the president and democrats haven't
tried to get these items over the finish
line they have but they've fallen short
and built back better they fell short of
the 50 votes needed through this budget
reconciliation process the other issues
that we're talking about are not budget
reconciliation issues these are
filibuster issues in the senate that
require 60 votes that at any given time
is at least 10 republicans getting on
board and so the idea that these big
ideas are
are going to get that kind of traction
uh are are unlikely so again i think it
pivots back to sort of
what do we want to tell voters we we
want to accomplish because these have
gotten votes not all of them but many of
these these ideas
have received some level of of voting in
in the united states senate though i
will say that protecting abortion rights
roe v wade
coming up in the supreme court in june
that may be a bigger issue
yeah i will say i'm surprised he didn't
devote more attention to that that was
an issue than looking back at that
virginia governor's race mcauliffe
focused on that quite some
for quite some time didn't end up
becoming a major issue in the end so i
wonder if they've they've done poland
they've seen focus groups showing
abortion isn't quite the issue that it
was once seen as finally gentlemen
iowa governor
reynolds gave the republican rebuttal
she did
she did as one democratic strategist and
fox news contributor said um a list of
of grievances gop grievances rather than
a proposed list of solutions i thought
that was was interesting he compared
really her to newt gingrich and then
this idea of coming up with a contract
for america coming up with proposed
solutions
the things reynolds mentioned
parents
what's being taught in schools covid
these things matter to a lot of
republican and independent voters is it
fair to say this was just an airing of
grievances or
yeah these aren't just i mean they're
grievances but they're much more than
that i mean when you combine the culture
war with quality of life issues that is
about as politically potent uh
combination as you can get and it's
benefiting the republicans i mean
education is an issue for example where
democrats had 15 20-point advantages for
my whole life
in in in in congressional elections
republicans in the latest washington
post poll narrowed it to three points
that's a significant seismic shift uh
and you know you also have coveted
policies and everything that the
president was talking about and i'd give
him credit for adapting
and he didn't have many masks at all in
the hall today
that was a sign that they saw the
frustration and the politics of
these restrictions just being not
supported by most voters
well thank you gentlemen fox news radio
political analyst and against the grain
columnist at the national journal josh
crosshauer and fox news radio washington
dc correspondent jared halpern thank you
both for your time thanks thanks jessica
[Music]
this is david marcus with your fox news
commentary
coming up
congresswoman liz chaney was one of 10
house republicans who voted to impeach
then president trump over the capital
riots there are some times when you do
have to say you know
partisanship has to be put aside shaney
calls herself a strong conservative but
the only way the republican party can go
forward in strength is if we reject the
lie if we reject what happened on
january 6 if we reject the efforts that
president trump made frankly to steal
the election the congresswoman went
further joining adam kinzinger who also
voted to impeach as the only republicans
on the democrat-led house committee
investigating the capital riot and last
month both were censured by the
republican national committee kenzinger
has decided not to run for re-election
in illinois cheyney wants to keep her
job but several republicans are trying
to unseat her in wyoming led by harriet
hagenman who's been endorsed by the
former president police cheney doesn't
live in wyoming she hasn't lived in
wyoming
she bought a house here in 2012 but she
lives in northern virginia with her
family hegemon started thinking about
running in 2020 then but when she
participated in what was a sham
impeachment without due process i was
really pretty disgusted and so not only
did i start thinking seriously about it
but i started having people all over the
state of wyoming contacting me and
saying would you consider running
against her i kept thinking at some
point she was going to back down and
kind of recognize the error of her ways
but keep in mind i'm a water and natural
resource attorney i'm a trial attorney
and have been for over 30 or for about
33 years
so the concept of due process is pretty
incredibly important to me and when i
watched what was going on with the
impeachment the lack of due process the
lack of information it was clearly a
railroad job it was clearly done uh it
to be expedited so that no one could say
hey wait a minute what really did happen
here and uh i didn't like that
now as you go around the state and you
talk to people you've been in wyoming
for many years
she's not been out there campaigning she
hasn't been around the state as much as
you so you pretty much have the state to
yourself at the moment right yes
which is a rather odd circumstance isn't
it and it really proves my point that i
made earlier that is she doesn't come
from wyoming she doesn't live in wyoming
and she doesn't have the wyoming values
so i i've traveled over 14 000 miles by
car in wyoming since september and i go
to town halls and i have two and three
hour town halls and i have from the
beginning i've made it to every county
most of them multiple times i was just
at cpac this past weekend which was
absolutely fabulous but yes i'm working
very very hard to get out and meet with
the folks in wyoming
from what i can tell from liz the couple
of times that she does come into this
state she tends to go to the press she
sits down with them and i think she uses
that as a surrogate with talking with
actual people in the state and then she
will go and have a private event at
someone's private home with you know
four five six people but that's kind of
the extent of her campaigning now she
has been of course censured by the
republican party so what she said was
she's not going to convince the crazies
and she said she rejects the crazies and
she says that that people against her
have abandoned the constitution i think
she's obviously relating back to what
happened with the president and the
election fraud claims and all that that
happened in in late 2020 and early 2021
what's your response to that well a
couple of things i don't think that you
ought to call your constituents crazies
and simply because someone disagrees
with her or with me
i don't believe that that makes them
crazy i may i think that that means that
they disagree with me or they disagree
with her we have a legitimate right to
disagree with our government and our
government officials in this country
that's one of the things that makes us
unique
and and it i think that it really
demonstrates the arrogance with which
she approaches this office that you're
either with her you're against her and
she doesn't have any interest in
convincing you she's right she's just
right you're wrong and not only are you
wrong you're crazy she was censored
because she is not doing what we sent
her to washington dc to do in fact she's
doing exactly the opposite
which is we have a failure of an
administration with the biden pelosi
radical left radical green agenda right
now and i threw in the latter part
because we're looking at a disaster in
the ukraine and in europe right now
because of bad energy policies
that's what i talked about at cpac this
past week and energy security is
national security and one of the very
first things that this administration
did when it came into office was destroy
our
energy independence
that is a big deal to me it's a big deal
to me because i come from wyoming one of
one of the top energy producing states
in the nation so our jobs are very
dependent on it it's of great interest
to me because i'm an american and i
believe in protecting our shores and and
and protecting the stability in this
country uh the president's pushing a
more
clean energy agenda he has climate
change initiatives and he believes that
you know we need to do more to
change our approach to climate change
for global warming and all that kind of
stuff
what would you do
in congress to try to find a middle
ground if there is a middle ground on
any of that energy issue
well the reality is is that
our ability to protect our environment
and take care of our environment is
direct
is directly proportional to our
prosperity you destroy our economy and
that's one of the very first things
that's going to go by the wayside you
can't come in and destroy your economy
and then expect that we're going to be
able to spend millions if not billions
upon those types of things the other
thing is that our energy is clean we do
protect the environment here
we're incredibly environmentally sound
and in fact to the extent that they're
pumping gas or lng in
in
russia it's dirtier than what you have
in the united states so producing these
energy supplies in the united states
actually protects the environment it
doesn't destroy the environment you can
take a tour of any one of our coal mines
in wyoming and see the reclamation that
they've done you can see the areas that
are used by the wildlife you can see the
incredible grass and pasture land that
they have created you look at the same
with our oil and gas industry they can
talk about being carbon free by 2030 or
2035 and they can talk about doing away
with the oil and gas industry or the
coal industry and absolutely none of
that is feasible now she said the biden
administration's destroying the economy
democrats would disagree there was seven
percent economic growth last quarter and
for all of last year gdp growth was
almost six percent the most since 1984.
however inflation is still at a 40-year
high as we keep paying more for more
things
you don't just wake up one day and say
oh my goodness gracious look at that
inflation out there on the yard it is
something that happens because of the
policies that they adopted killing the
exile pipeline
the the border the the absolute disaster
at our southern border the inflation is
real and it is tied to the policies of
this administration they are affecting
real kitchen table issues with people
around this country right you you
mentioned earlier that there was a sham
impeachment for uh
for president trump as he was leaving
office you said that they didn't have
the information at the time well now
more than a year later the investigation
does continue i know she's on the house
committee with democrats probing what
happened that day
why would that be a bad idea to continue
to investigate what happened a year ago
we have more than 700 people who face
criminal charges a trial this week is
the first one to start others have pled
guilty why would we not want to
investigate that day i'm not necessarily
opposed to the investigation
but when it is completely and totally
one-sided whatever comes out of that
investigation is not going to tell us
what happened that day it's going to
tell us one version of what happened
that day the reason that they kicked jim
banks and jim jordan off of the
committee was they didn't want them to
ask the uncomfortable questions if
you're going to do an investigation the
uncomfortable questions are the ones
that are the most important in my book
so if you're going to have an
investigation there's a legitimate
reason as to why both democrats and
republicans are appointed by their
respective leadership adam kinsenger and
liz cheney were not appointed by kevin
mccarthy they were appointed by nancy
pelosi there's nobody on the other side
and and you've got to have the other
side you have to have the other story
being told you have to have the other
evidence coming in
that's what they're excluding okay so
all right what about what about the
former president do you do you have
concerns about what he did that day he
went and he addressed a rally right
before the people went into the capitol
we can't accept the the election was
stolen from us i mean do you have any
concerns about how he handled that day
you know i was not there i was i i
wasn't there for that i didn't see it
and and to be honest with you i haven't
even seen much by way of video i'd like
to see the 14 000 hours of videotape
that the capitol police and the and and
the municipal police have i'd love to
see all of that i'd love to see what
happens there do i think that donald
trump uses interesting rhetoric sure but
we all know the way that donald trump
speaks and one of the things that donald
trump made very clear that day is go up
there and peaceably assemble
anybody who i have said over and over
again anyone who trespassed or destroyed
property that day should be prosecuted
pursuant to the laws and as you
mentioned at the very beginning of this
discussion they are they are being
prosecuted that apparently is not good
enough for this january 6th committee
because they have a different agenda
harriet hageman got to see former
president trump at cpac he told the
conservative gathering vladimir putin
would never have invaded ukraine on his
watch he understood me
and he understood that i didn't play
games this would not have happened
democrats criticized him for calling the
russian leaders smart of course
but the
real problem is that our leaders are
dumb the former president easily won a
poll at cpac for who they want as the
republican nominee in 2024. now back in
2016 harriet hageman was not a trump
supporter she backed ted cruz then one
of his convention delegates i mean i'm
from wyoming ted cruz is from texas
another oil producing state western
state i thought that he would truly
understand our issues and i had some
skepticism as to whether a a guy from
new york city would what did he do he
did what he said he was going to do
that's the thing people keep bringing
this back well you didn't you didn't
support him in 2016.
he walked into office and he did what he
said he was going to do he made us
energy independent he did close the
border
his support what does it mean to you
well
his support as well as others um it
means a ton first of all i met with him
he had an opportunity to discuss with me
these various policy issues that are
important to both of us
so one of the things that it did is it
helped narrow this field down so that
this is going to be a head-to-head
battle between liz cheney and i and
while the democrats in wyoming have made
clear that they are going to vote for
liz cheney there are not enough of them
to put her back in office if this is a
head-to-head between us so that's
important also the ability to raise
money
having his endorsement having his vote
of confidence some of the other
endorsements are important as well in
part for the same reason but also in
part because they're such huge
no-confidence votes against liz cheney
you know as a congresswoman you
recognize you're one of 435 people and
if you can't work with your colleagues
you can't accomplish anything and that's
where she is she can't work with her
colleagues she has a very small subset
of friends uh about nine of them the
other folks who voted for impeachment
and nancy pelosi and those folks
situationally but she's really burned
every bridge she has back in washington
dc so she cannot work on the issues that
are important to us harriet hageman
republican candidate for congress in the
state of wyoming we thank you very much
for your time today dave thank you for
having me
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever changing times you can rely
on fox news for hourly updates for the
very latest news and information on your
time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts rate and review
the fox news rundown on apple podcasts
or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
david marcus
what's on your mind in 2020 ash
wednesday the beginning of lent for
christians fell on february 26th
it was one of the last days of normalcy
before our descent into pandemic
lockdown
for most of those 40 days nobody had to
decide what to give up for lent because
almost everyone gave up everything
that easter sunday like no other was the
first holiday in isolation
this week lent begins again and it feels
like more than a coincidence that it
coincides with what seems to be the
final gasps of covet restriction
christians in our blue cities where
prohibitions lingered are entering this
period of sacrifice and self-reflection
as their lives return to something like
normal
so what should we give up for this land
my humble suggestion is that we seek to
forego anger and ego over the coming
weeks
for those of us who have long opposed
the absurd and overreaching measures of
the past two years the urge to gloat is
overwhelming we were called murderers
grandma killers science deniers and
worse
now the overwhelming evidence shows we
were right all along but how should we
handle that
here a distinction should be made those
in power the politicians public health
officials tv news anchors should be held
to account and forced to admit how
devastatingly wrong they were after all
this must never happen again
but when it comes to our personal
relations our friends family co-workers
a more gentle approach is not only moral
it's practical
over the coming weeks on social media
and in our conversations we will observe
a stunning setup first since the
pandemic started
first time my kids have been in a
restaurant first time i'm maskless at
church first time in person with my
favorite sibling this kind of thing
before our jaws drop and out comes the
snark we should think for a moment and
suspend our natural urge to judge
first of all this is an act of kindness
in keeping with lent
many who trusted the fauci and his
minions know on some level that they
were duped that indeed they made many
sacrifices in vain but unlike democrat
governors and big tech oligarchs they
did not do so in order to gain
power or profit but from sincere concern
for themselves and their fellow man
that is admirable
secondly there is an element of
enlightened self-interest here providing
a face-saving landing strip for the
covet obsessed may well make them more
likely to resist such measures in the
future
understanding will go a lot farther than
backing them into a corner
lent is a time for christians to
understand just how unworthy we are of
god's love and yet how generous he is in
bestowing it what he asks in return is
that we seek to emulate him though our
efforts are often flawed grasping and
childish
in the coming weeks we have a chance to
comfort or condemn help or
humiliate during the origin of lent
christ was tempted in the desert with
mastery of the universe today all we are
tempted with is a sarcastic comment or
facebook post
surely that can be given up to the lord
and we can find peace in doing so
better that our loved ones remove the
splinter of covet hysteria from their
own eyes
this year when easter comes and your
family members who have locked
themselves inside for two years are
finally back don't scoff just be glad
after all it is good to be right but it
is right to be good
this is david marcus author of charade
the coveted lies to crush the nation
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes